[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi ce que j'aime ce que j'aime c'est ce
genre d'union tu sers la magouille la
personne merci
elle était en clientèle on va mais j'ai
fermé les yeux
ah oui mais vous n'auriez pas dû
normalement mais très très jolie fille
et c'est vraiment un bon c'est dangereux
parce qu'il est chaud conclut gérard
entamé en une attraction
mais les choses sérieuses en soirée la
magnifique où les alors les aime for
baby sitting qui avaient été invités à
parfaire sa stature
qu'est ce qu'un faux pas le jamais le
faire c'est parce que michel avec toute
l'amitié il est comme il est chauve
c'est gérard icg
[Applaudissements]
c'est mieux cette pâte à sel blanc
[Rires]
je sauterai ballon sera aussi bon c'est
la faute aux cas c'est françois qui va
décider
dix ans aucune sanction après assez
basse et françois qui décide à nongo
mieux gérard est un peu chaud ce genre
d'exercice est vrai que sa liste de fer
vont tout ce dont vous avez le faire
et nous a manqué la semaine dernière il
a pas de surmoi où il se dit pour palaja
d'une audience
[Rires]